[Music]
things have been sportified
and this is where it goes back to even
our last conversations when i say
how people have
how i feel that competition is the
opposite of creativity
yeah this is so key i highlighted that
when i reviewed our our first
conversation i'd love for you to just
elaborate on that i will i will because
i it's something that's that i've been
challenged on people like but you
without competition you'll never get
better and you gotta have competition
you gotta and i said no you don't you do
not have to compete
with
other human beings
now the thing is you don't need
competition but you do need resistance
two different things
this is the work the fact that you get
up is a resisting it's you're gonna face
resistance
with going outside the wind is fighting
you you know when you if you plant
something weeds are automatically grow
they grow up anything good is attacked
you have to build a house you have to
everything is so easy for entropy to
happen but everything that's worth
something has to be built has to be
redesigned it has to be created and it
has to you automatically have resistance
but competition however i think
you know imagine if the world had
evolved through competition there would
only be
one set of people
it doesn't work that way the world
evolved through
collaboration that's how i feel society
evolved that's how humanity evolved
it's all through collaboration
but again that revenge movie that whole
thing that we live it's about
competition it's about putting me on top
and now i'm on top
and i gotta cancel everybody else and
and so and so you gotta go down and i am
the winner and you're the loser
and
this is a it's a sportification it's
like i won i beat everybody i'm the best
in the world
today it's king of the hill
but someone's coming to kick you off
and when you live those rules it's kind
of like if you if you go
your whole life canceling everybody you
eventually have to cancel yourself
because you're not perfect you know i
mean it's like
one thing that gets me man hollywood
loves to point the fingers at everybody
and hollywood on the at the academy
awards it actually canceled itself
which blew my mind
the standing ovation after the assault
i was everyone was sitting there like at
home like what
you canceled yourself
this is crazy yeah and you realize wait
a minute
now when i go when i go into
collaboration
when you realize that the world is a
house
and this is the thing and the world this
is the way guys like to play where it's
like hey man i i'm on my side of the
house i got the kitchen the kitchen is
mine i can cook whatever i want and
they'll flaunt it like i got all this
kitchen and it's all mine but other guys
like well check it out i'm on this side
of the house i have the bathroom i can
take a shower i'm clean i'm good
well tim eventually
the guy in the kitchen's got to use the
bathroom
and the guy with the bathroom's gotta
use the kitchen
you see what i'm saying like
now this is the problem because if it's
a sport
who won
who won yeah yeah right today the guy
with the bathroom
but tomorrow the guy with the kitchen
and it's endless
and when you do that what you're doing
it to me it's like
you know
this is a phrase i love to use and there
was a lot being said i i said things
about
what was going on with black lives
matter what was going on with a lot of
our culture during this whole time
and i my issue was that any
movement that doesn't start
with reconciliation
i don't want any part of
we have to reconcile we have to
reconcile men to women
we have to reconcile black to white
we have to reconcile republican to
democrat
we have to we have to reconcile that's
the first
rule because if we don't
what you're doing is postponing a war
that's all you're doing
it's postponing it it's a matter of okay
you know we strike the day
and we'll have to wait and then we'll
get our get our bearings together and
we'll strike again later and then they
come get you and you come get them
but with reconciliation
there's an agreement
with reconciliation there's an
understanding
this reconciliation is peace wherever
you are reconciled there's going to be
peace
you know
and
i
knew and i i got in a lot of trouble at
the time
for talking about hey i
decide to unite with good people black
and white
no matter the race
no matter the color
no matter the creed no matter the
ideology
i said i am going to unify with good
people and
i was
i was really put through the wringer for
that
but i feel really good about it because
i made my stand in the middle
of a lot of name calling a lot of
people who wanted to fight
and
and listen i understood the anger
i understood it i was that guy
you know what i mean i was like
but i realized if we if we just turn
over the chess board every time
we're not going to get anywhere you know
what i mean it's like
these kind of things have to be
there's no winning until we reconcile
there's no sometimes you got to stop
playing the game
you know what i mean and when i say a
game that's exactly what i'm talking
about you have to walk off the court
and say we're not playing today
now we're gonna we're gonna work
together
you